see was President Obama's national
security director and United Nations
ambassador his new memoir is tough-love
my story of the things worth fighting
for a Susan Rice
[Applause]
[Music]
first thing I wanted to ask you your
Susan Rice you know in showbiz is
everybody gets mixed up at some point
with somebody else right everybody
doesn't okay there are people who have
thought I was Bill O'Reilly that's
unfortunate
I'm never going to that strip club again
but I just had some people must do think
you're Condoleezza Rice it happens and
used to piss my mother off more than
anything else my late mother when she
got asked are you Condoleezza Rice's
mother and yeah we we have ties to
Stanford we were both national security
advisors who were both black women named
rice and so you know it happens to me in
airports it happens to me all over the
place where people say you worked with
President Bush yeah President Bush's
national security advisor and Secretary
of State no but the funniest time was
when I was visiting China for the first
time as national security advisor on my
own mission on behalf of President Obama
and I met with President Xi and I'm
setting up a summit and CCTV does a
whole big spread on the nightly news and
they say you know Susan Rice is in China
to see President Xi and they put up
Connie's picture oh that [ __ ] happens to
black folks
well glad we could come here to HBO and
say it for real I hope they I so it was
very interesting in your book you
mentioned your mother
you made your career partly as a
mediator and you sort of learned that
because your parents were squabbling
more than but as a very young girl you
say seven years old you were doing
diplomacy at home well unfortunately my
brother and I were living in a house
that was a tinderbox I had two really
wonderful extremely accomplished parents
but they had no business being married
and their breakup was very ugly and
sometimes even violent and I'd be trying
to get to sleep upstairs as a little kid
and if I couldn't I'd run downstairs and
sort of spy on them and see how bad it
was and if it was really bad I'd go in
there and try to break it up sometimes
physically but also sometimes mediating
between them trying to listen to each
side and help them you did shuttle
diplomacy well was he shuttle it was you
know like proximity talks in in my own
house but I bet you that served you well
ended well it turned out but that wasn't
the plan at the time I was just trying
to keep my house from burning down right
well speaking of houses burning down
yeah I I just have to what you must
think with what went on this week in the
last week in the Middle East now I
remember from decades people talking
about who lost that was the who lost
China right foolosophy who lost Syria
you know I saw the Turkish Defense
Minister put up the new map of Turkey
with a big chunk of Syria he bit off
parts of Iraq Greece you know I remember
when George Bush went into Iraq in 2003
the idea embraced by some liberals was
we have to remake the Middle East we're
gonna put a democracy in the heart of
the Arab world okay that didn't work out
but Trump and Bush together they have
remade the Middle East well Trump
especially in the last week it's amazing
well Iraq
how much Iranian yeah Iraq now serious
white or do you see this going it's
going nowhere good I mean what Trump is
done in Iraq and now Syria is
effect to seed a portion of northern
Syria Kurdish homeland to the Turks and
to evacuate the Americans as if it's you
know his Saigon we've left our Turkish
allies homeless they're now going to
scatter throughout the region we've
given Assad and and Putin and the
Iranians a green light to take over that
territory that they've been long wanting
to take and Isis is going to come back
but Assad is gonna be okay with turkey
biting off of a chunk of his land well
if you're if you're Assad last week you
were missing a third of your country now
you're just missing a little sliver on
the top wow that's a that's not bad for
one week's work and watching Republicans
not get that upset about this more than
upset than we've seen but not to the
point of we should get rid of them must
infuriate you having lived through
Benghazi that that was something that
required hearing after hearing after
hearing eight congressional inquiries
yeah there's really no comparison I mean
look it was not a good thing that
happened in Benghazi but the idea that
anyone could have stopped that well
Benghazi what a horrible tragedy right
we lost four Americans including
ambassador but what we're gonna lose as
a result of what Donald Trump has done
in Syria is we're gonna have a whole
terrorist resurgence as a result of his
pullout so we'll see the ramifications
of that in American and allied lives I
think I'm afraid for years to come
you don't worries me I think back to
9/11 and I imagine after it happened bin
Laden was saying to himself wow I didn't
think they would destroy themselves this
easily I knew this was going to be a win
for us
but we knocked down those buildings they
overreacted they attacked the wrong
country they spent trillions of dollars
the Homeland Security Department that's
a big bloated bureaucracy this whole
mess Putin in 2016 spent a pittance and
got Trump elected or certainly helped
what do you think about the fact that
idea that we're just it's just too easy
to get Americans to destroy themselves
well what is I think happening now and
what
Putin's geniuses is that he understands
that we are so divided internally and
that if I argue in my book of love that
our domestic political divisions are in
fact our greatest national security
vulnerability we can't get stuff done we
can't build infrastructure we can't
invest in technology to beat the Chinese
and artificial intelligence but we've
also found ourselves so pitted against
one another that all putin had to do was
jump in and exacerbate those divisions
pour salt in the wounds and we are now
almost like a flesh-eating disease
eating ourselves alive I think we have
the ability to fix it because it's a
problem of our own making our domestic
divisions well we have to stop hating
each other absolutely you know I mean to
me the Rubicon was crossed when one
party the Republican Party said I am you
see the t-shirts at Trump rallies I'd
rather be with the Russians and the
Democrats we never sort of went there
like - yeah I don't like the other
political party but I'm not gonna go
over to a foreign country that's to me
the big difference when we somehow went
there how do you get back from that well
Bill I mean I it's horrible and to say
you'd rather be with you know our enemy
than your fellow American is I think a
new low but you get back from it by what
we do as individuals in terms of our
personal relationships listening hearing
it's what we do as a nation where we
really need to change a lot of the rules
of the game which are inviting these
extremes to be empowered I think we
should stop talking politics to each
other that's part of it we didn't used
to do it all the time
we had no idea how much we hated each
other I've got a very conservative son
conservatives I've got a very
conservative son and a very progressive
daughter and my husband and I are in
between and one thing I've learned from
having those differences in my very home
at my dinner table is we can't talk
about it all the time because we drive
ourselves crazy but you can't not talk
of you leave but not all the time and
then we've got to do some stuff I think
at a national level like mandatory
national service for all Americans 18 to
22
for six to twelve months for six to
twelve months get them all together and
we we had to understand each other from
you know some rural kid from Idaho
having to work with some kid from the
south blocks right that would it's hard
to hate people when you actually know
them alright last question Edward snowed
[Applause]
I know you I mean you're not easy on him
no you say he has done immeasurable
damage yes he says the opposite you well
I'm asking you yeah I mean and I usually
side with people in your business I was
never one of those liberals who said oh
no I don't trust the CIA I don't trust
the air but I do in general I think
they're Patriots you're right so I don't
think Edward Snowden is a traitor like
Alden or Walker people who did it for
money who were trying to sell out their
country for themselves I think he really
thinks he's doing a good thing but what
say you you say he's a traitor and I
mean that with great sincerity I say
that because I know what he did he stole
the most sensitive information
you know things we gave it to people who
had no business having it he's sitting
in Moscow littered Herzog yes we are you
know that I do know that I know we are
profoundly less secure as a result of
what he did we're trying to recover but
that recovery is going to take a long
time and let me tell you the reason I'm
so blunt about what he did in the book
is because I know quite how bad what he
did is and I'm not here to ascribe
motives you know maybe he did it for
what he thought were benign reasons but
the impact of what he did is what I want
people to understand and why I go so far
as to use a word that I have no no no I
get it
it's so interesting that the Democrats
are the ones now who understand what
treason and patriotism is we understand
what national security is I know you do
Susan Rice thank you
[Applause]
you